Monday there was an opportunity for head
coach Bill O'Brien to discuss the
aftermath of these deals which has
resulted in intense criticism criticism
of the Texans a team that has no general
manager and it showed let's listen to
what Bill O'Brien said in response to
the criticism that the team has absorbed
in the aftermath of those trades that
were made on Saturday I understand
everybody's gonna dissect you know how
we did it and what we received back and
what we gave Seattle we're very
confident we're also confident in the
fact that we can't control what the
outside world thinks you know that's you
said it you know that's the nature of
our business it's probably taken me a
while to figure that out you know but
it's the nature of our business I think
the best thing for us to do is go work
hard practice hard and win you know the
specific context of the question was the
Seattle trade for Jadeveon Clowney but
you have the the two first-round picks
in the second-round pick that were
surrendered guys for Laremy Tunsil and
Kenny Stills to the Miami Dolphins big
picture the criticism inevitable is the
criticism fair Peter well Mike if if
they had gotten a contract extension
with Laremy Tunsil if they had called
Tunsil and his agent you know and say
hey look you got five hours to decide
five years ninety million fifty million
guaranteed if you want to take it we're
gonna do this deal if not we're not you
know and then they could have gotten
Laremy Tunsil and an extension done for
18 million a year or maybe 19 if they
had to really go that far but at the end
of this year you know what's gonna
happen
Laremy Tunsil is gonna be able to hold
him hostage because even though he could
be you know extended he could be
franchised in - 2021 but i think the
biggest problem is our I'm sorry 2020
the biggest problem Mike is I don't
think the compensation was horrible I
think it was excessive but I don't think
it was horrible but it wasn't good that
they didn't get that extension yeah I
agree with you and hopefully that's one
of those things or at least for the
Houston Texans case it's one of those
things that they get a contract
extension done at
the first half of this season you're
right because they're gonna look
ridiculous if Tunsil walks out the door
as a free agent or something like that
and they traded route traded first-round
picks I'll say this much about the whole
weekend for the Houston Texans first off
the trade for the Seattle Seahawks is
phenomenal I mean we know that Seattle
was a Super Bowl contender or at least a
playoff contender now there are a true
Super Bowl winning contender I think
would Evian Clowney the Houston Texans
okay I got no issue as much with the
Jeff Jadeveon Clowney trade Mike and
Peter but it is the Miami trade where I
go wow that's crazy
Laremy Tunsil is a fine player but he
has not proven himself to be anywhere in
the top five tackles and all a football
conversation yet we know that the Miami
Dolphins wanted to get rid of Kenny
Stills because of the whole Steven Ross
situation to me that's the one that
doesn't make sense they gave up a lot of
value and future draft picks of course
to really frame their team to get a guy
who's a third mate receiver maybe is a
bottom end number two in Stills and then
of course in Tunsil who's hasn't lived
up to his top ten billing yet as a draft
pick and I agree with make one point to
you Chris yeah Mike can I just interrupt
I want to make one point good
so Kenny Stills the value instills yeah
is as much as durability he's missed two
games in six years and they've got
they've got some some guys on their
roster in Houston who've missed a lot of
time or willful so that was part of his
value yeah yeah you know I think he is a
valuable piece of this trade the
question though is really if you'd have
done a straight-up deal for Kenny Stills
with the Dolphins what could you have
gotten him for and it's hard to parse it
out because so much was included in
there and at one point we thought you
know flowey bright we thought you'd even
clown he was gonna be part of that deal
with the Miami Dolphins but he was able
to engineer his situation away from
Miami and toward Seattle by not signing
the franchise tender he met with the
media yesterday and he was asked the
specific question of whether he was
influenced by what lay beyond Bill did
last year to hold out all year long and
dictate where he was going to play in
2019 how much of that influenced you
Davey on clowny here's his
response when he was asked that question
by reporters I just kind of really
started to take control of what I could
control as far as what can i play and
how can I be traded as far as that uh so
I was just taking taking that to
consideration was like almost out of tad
maybe I can decide way and I'm going it
I got somewhere willing to be
I mean it is amazing he was able to pull
that off and I think about the deal that
brought Tunsil instills to Houston and
what Houston gave up if you throw clowny
into that mix and send him to Miami
you're probably are keeping your
second-round pick right clowny and two
ones for Tunsil and Kenny still sounds
like a pretty good deal but clowny
wasn't having it he wasn't gonna sign
his franchise tender or at least he said
he wasn't gonna sign it and he got to
engineer his path to Seattle Peter is
this the next brick in this wall of
players developing power over there
their situation in the NFL or is it just
an aberration no I think it's good for
Jadeveon Clowney he obviously once he
found out that they were trying to trade
him in Houston I think he said look I'm
not going to a 1 in 15 team I'm not
going to the Miami Dolphins forget that
I'm not going from a playoff contender
to up to a bad team and so he basically
could put the kibosh on that but Mike
the bigger question I think I would my
two-part question about this and and
don't get me wrong I like this trade for
Seattle without any question especially
because they're only paying half his
salary right I really like this question
this trade but what is everybody gonna
say about this trade if after this year
Jadeveon Clowney signs for 23 million a
year with the pick a team the Detroit
Lions and then he becomes a one-year
rental for the Seahawks there you know I
still think people are gonna say hey it
was a good a good gamble for them to
take I get it but this is a one-year
deal so everybody who's saying and I
also said that John Schneider won the
weekend so I like this but I'm not sure
first of all the Seattle Seahawks
have some holes on their roster none
bigger by the way then it pass rusher so
that was great they got some holes on
their roster and they got some holes in
the defensive secondary you have no idea
how their receiving corps is going to be
and they still have an offensive line
that has trouble protecting Russell
Wilson so this is not the you know I
disagree with Chris I don't think this
is this puts them over the top as being
a legitimate Super Bowl contender yeah I
mean I mean it's okay you're allowed to
disagree with me I don't see it that way
the old I encourage it yeah well good
please do bring up on me on a Tuesday
morning that's what I like you know the
offensive line I think is is where it
needs to be they kind of proved it last
year I don't expect that to be a
weakness of this football team anymore
in the ball so much because it's not a
good run in not a good pass for sure
sure so we'll see we'll see where that
goes but still their ability to run the
ball I still think it's going to be
special you have Russell Wilson they
have some unproven commodities at
quarterback certainly but when you start
mean a wide receiver excuse me secondary
you're right Peter it's not like
household names but this is a grouping
people and Schneider and Carroll who
know what they're doing they know how to
evaluate young talent they've already
proven that to where yeah they're not
household names but I think it's better
than maybe people realize but when you
started getting into Ezekiel Lanza
Jadeveon Clowney first-round pick LJ
Collier and then okay John Ron Reed
who's gonna be suspended for the road
what is it the first six weeks Mike
maybe I'm wrong maybe s4 I mean when
that group gets back healthy I think
that puts them back in with now Bobby
Wagner okay and KJ right and Michael
Kendricks a linebacker I go watch out
that's one of the most versatile
athletic best front 7s in all of
football and we know the home field
advantage Seattle has up there in
general anyways loud crowd noise
defensive line can get a jump on the at
the start of the snap better than the
offense can and I think that's the
beauty of it and they're playing to the
bed to the way they built their first
Super Bowl team I think that's where I
look at it but you're right it's a
one-year rental but he's risky
he had microfracture surgery and there's
a you got to wait and see did with the
Jadeveon Clowney you can't just throw
him bucket loads of money at this point
yet he hasn't proved that but
like f up the play extraordinaire this
guy messes up more plays than anybody in
football not named Aaron Donnell the
last few years sorry I said I still need
to work on the Elias Sports Bureau to
get them to recognize the official stat
of the National Football League but what
here's the one this is one additional
criticism of the Texans yeah because
they all I had to say to Clowney was
look you're gonna give up a million
dollars a week and not sign the tender
we decide where we're gonna trade you
this is how it works you're gonna make
16 million dollars this year are you
really gonna give up a million dollars a
week to just sit there and cross your
arms and say I'm not going to Miami I
want to go to Seattle so you know to the
extent that we we think that players are
seizing control over teams it may be
that players are seizing control over
weak teams that are letting them because
if I'm the Texans GM wait there isn't
one if I'm anybody in a position of
influence with the Texans I'm saying
call this guy's Bluff he's not gonna
fail to sign that tender he's going to
show up and we're gonna be able to trade
him wherever we want to trade him and
when you consider what they got back for
him if he wants to sit out for four or
five weeks and give up four or five
million so be it that's his problem
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports